listening to
courage women David Raven
well normally when I'm doing a
consultation with filmmakers who have
joined open indie the main question the
main thing I'm looking for is to figure
out the wavelength that the film is on
and what else can be created that would
also be on that wavelength but that
would be smaller and shorter and and
allow you could say a viral spreading of
the project and over where pneus of what
the project is and what the project
feels like so in order to get into that
that the first question is is generally
about you know why did you guys make
this film like was to take everything
that we learned from four eyed monsters
and actually give that to other
filmmakers through a platform through a
community and hopefully in the process
change people's understandings of what
how much power they have as an audience
and also empower filmmakers to know how
much is possible if they actually open
up their film to the audience and let
people put on screenings and let you
know let people promote their film and
give them the tools to do that